start okay so welcome to the afternoon
session first talk is by yuliya Bircher
speaking on Patrick general graphs using
a pseudo randomness thank you very much
so am yeah let's talk I want to talk
about packing problems in graphs and
hypergraphs and what I want to do in the
talk is mainly give an overview about
what has happened in this very active
area in the last few years and I want to
highlight a little bit how pseudo
randomness used along the way to justify
that I talked about this in the
conference so let's see so the journey
and well okay I don't want to claim that
this is really whether the history of
this area starts because there's some
controversy tea and yeah it's not quite
clear what happened first and so on so
let me just clay and I don't want to get
into this so let me just say that my
story starts in London in this ladies
and gentlemen's diary in 1850 where Kirk
man who did a lot of mathematics at the
time but he was really a churchman so he
was yeah so a little bit of an outsider
but he asked the following problem so
that was a it's a recreational
mathematics genre and he asked the
following problem there so assume you
have 15 young ladies and they should
walk to the school and three of them
should always go together so you should
group them into groups of three and it
shall be too boring for them so on each
of the seven days they should walk in
different groups yeah so and that was
his question and now in modern language
we call such things Stennett repair
systems although here a little bit more
required but I will get back to that in
a second so what is this diner system in
general so I have some system and I have
three parameters TK a 10
and what I want to start with is an N
element set s and then I look at each of
the T element subsets of this of the set
s and I want to find a family of now K
element subsets of you should think of
T's maalik with AK small equal an N and
which can which are often called blocks
such that each of these three elements
subsets is contained in exactly one of
these blocks so here now example n would
be 15 and the blocks would be of size
three it's ok would be 3 and T is simply
too so no true should should be should
be there together now as I said I want
to talk about problems and graphs and
hypergraphs so let me immediately
translate that to the hypergraph
language which I want to use in the
following sorry
so in the language of hypergraphs and
this this ground sat at that would be my
set of vertices and then I would look at
the complete T uniform hyper graph on
this on the set of vertices so my hyper
edges would be these two subsets and
what I want to cover these t subsets
with our complete a complete graphs so
complete t uniform micrographs and i am
short just say t graphs with K vertices
in each of these yeah so that's a that's
a Steiner system and so [ __ ] man asks
for these particular parameters that
such a thing exists so does s 2 315 exes
but he wants a little bit more so
remember he wants these cougars already
partitioned into groups of three or
three girls so he somehow once that once
we do this once we find these complete k
graphs that and in this in this case
it's um it's just grass complete graphs
on three vertices so meaning triangles
and so he wants that once I have all
these triangles which should cover my
edges that I can furthermore partition
these triangles into into some parallel
classes yeah so that I have a set of
triangles which covers all the vertices
so all these 15 girls and and that is
one of my class and then I have another
one and so on and this is also what is
called a result of the Steiner system
okay and so an area of mathematics which
looks a lot of problems of this type is
called design theory and there one can
ask more general question so let me just
answer that I won't really get much back
to that the rest of the top one can ask
that I don't want just want to cover
each element each each of these hyper
edges ones but I can can cover
as time so that would give me another
parameter okay so that was the that's
the problem in general for hypergraphs
and that has that's a big open problem
and has been a big open problem and now
let's first look at this case of graphs
they don't have hyper growth spurt graph
so meaning that my parameter T here is
equal to 2 so quick man asked for
partitions in two triangles and a
theorem of russia to re-envision indeed
constructs or solves when such silence
systems exists so these systems s 2 3
and so again I have a graph and I want
to cover with triangles and over it
should be resolved that the name day I
get discovering of the vertices with
triangle and it is exactly when n is
congruent to 3 modulo 6 so where does
this funny condition come from that
there are some very obvious divisibility
conditions that you need when you want
to show that problem and now here what
are the conditions first of all what's
the number of edges in your graphs and
two so should be divisible by 3 because
we want to cover we want to pack yeah so
we want to partition the set of edges
into triangles moreover and mean n minus
1 should be even because now if you look
at one particular vertex and then all
the triangles which lie in this one
vertex then at the vertex you will see n
minus 1 edges and so n minus 1 should be
even because each triangle they use to M
of the edges at this vertex and then one
over n should be divisible by 3 so that
i get these parallel classes you know so
that i get a professional two triangles
of all these vertices and now if you
translate these conditions bag then you
can easily see that that's exactly the
same as saying that ends module is
congruent to three modules or six and in
fact their serum does not only look at
the case where
k is equal to three but looks at general
parameters K so the case then I want to
find when I want to cover the edges of
my graph this complete graphs on K
vertices and I want to do that in this
resolve with fashion ok so for grabs we
understand what we understood the
situation for a long time and now the
question is of course how about more
general hypergraphs and that was really
a very difficult problem and open for a
very long time and now what do you do if
you have some problem which is difficult
and you cannot solve and maybe you first
asked some simpler problem yeah and some
same problem was answered also family by
order and that kind of weakened the
problem in a little bit in the sense
that we know only ask for near Steiner
systems meaning we don't want to cover
all the hyper edges with complete clicks
but we are allowed to have a small left
over yeah and so in this theorem n
already serum then i right k and to the
teeth to denote the complete t graph on
n vertices now what is the theorem the
theorem is that we can partition the
edges of this complete t graph into h
discerns clicks on k vertices for any
parameters T and K almost not quite but
almost there will be some small left
over which is just a small fraction so
epsilon justice more constant bigger
than 0 which you can choose as small as
you want and so this leaves a very small
fraction of the edges uncovered so that
was in 85 and it's an important theorem
but what was even more important was the
method that will invent it in order to
prove this theorem which is by now
called would a nibble method so what is
the idea the idea is well
maybe somehow want to use a random
process in order tool to show something
like this because it seemed very
difficult to come up with explicit
constructions and so on so let's try to
do it randomly and then the first idea
of course that you should have is that
you also you want to find these please
clicks on K vertices in your tea graph
and now the first thing you could try is
to just select them randomly and that's
exactly what the proof does the problem
is just at some point when you do that
you get stuck and because at some point
when you selected many of them then they
will start to overlap a lot and of
course you want them to be edge disjoint
so that's not good and then what is idea
was well let's still do the same thing
but lads from time to time pause and
think a little bit so he proceeds and
round and that's exactly this thing of
selecting kk copies kk t copies randomly
and but only so long as we don't have
many overlaps in these kk to you copies
yeah so we're a few overlaps and then at
some point people stop and okay we don't
want any overlap so let's just throw
away those kkt copies where we have a
actually have some overlaps in this
process and let's take whatever remains
so that's a perfectly nice selection of
these three copies but now let's really
take them out of the graph yeah so i
started with the complete g graph on n
vertices and now I took some edge
disjoint kk copies away and now the hope
is that whatever i'm left with that can
repeat this random process again yeah
and kind of to make this precise of why
convenient then repeat this random
process again is exactly using some
pseudo randomness properties yeah so
what little shows is that whenever you
do one of your rounds of taking away
these kkt copies then whatever remains
they still have
nice pseudo randomness property so
that's the first time that pseudo
randomness comes in but let me not now
mention what precisely pseudo-random
this means here but it's it's a fairly
easy formulation of of pseudo randomness
properties okay so that except list this
please add and and this general Pru
philosophy has really been useful for
many many other problems in this area
but also in other areas since then and
it will appear a few more times
throughout the talk okay so that is that
is stablish dead for any uniformity of
my hypo graph we can get these new stine
assistance and more generally just
because i mentioned designs at the
beginning more generally you can do the
same for designs meaning where you don't
cover it just once but another fixed
number of times okay good and and then
it took a very long time until this neon
solution of the problem could be turned
into a full solution of the problem and
that was finally announced by key wash
in belief was 2014 and that now the
problem can actually be so yeah so what
his theorem says and it was really a big
bag through is that as long as n is
large enough if the obvious the
visibility conditions are satisfied what
do I mean by obviously visibility
conditions where I wrote them down here
but basically what you have to do is so
I did this exercise for the triangles of
what kind of divisibility conditions for
needs and now you have to do the same
thing in the general case but let me not
go into how you get exactly these but
it's it's it's not difficult so these
are the obvious conditions that you need
in order to get one of these Shriner
systems and his result says that indeed
then you get one and just one remark now
of course so it's theorem is for lodge
and we know that we need to have some
bound on ends or somehow for small n
desam counter examples to this but
probably we don't need an
quite as large as he gets from okay so
we know wendy's china system is exists
now what's the main idea of his proof i
won't verbally say less than a pound
about but so the main idea is to start
off from this result about near steiner
systems from reader and then well we can
only almost do it so we should think
about what do we now do in order to get
from this near result to a fair result
and in philosophy he uses some method
which has become very important in
combinatorics in the last few years and
and really been used on many problems
and that's the so-called absorbing
method and again i don't want to say
much about this and i just want to give
you the very basic philosophy so that so
we have so for these kind of problems
that i'm talking about here this method
goes back to some paper of good fortune
ski and summer already but already in
some earlier paper of people even some
similar methods were used okay so what
is the what is the basic philosophy and
the basic philosophy or is ok we somehow
have some random process of doing
whatever we want to do in this case we
want to find these different cliques and
we've at the end we will have a leftover
so if we know that we have a leftover
then and then once once we are there and
we have this leftover maybe there's not
much anymore that we can do so what you
should rather do is preparing for this
leftover right at the beginning so
meaning before we started in the process
we somehow find some clever structure
that will allow us and in the end
whatever our leftover will be to absorb
it that way it's called absorbing method
meaning to turn this leftover then
together with the clever structure into
a perfect covering with these and so
that's that's the main philosophy of the
of the year of the absorbing method
method and val Kiva's poses is a very
a sophisticated variation of this method
and loses a lot of algebraic structure
and so on but the underlying idea is
this and maybe one other remark I should
make it said very recently there was
some Aeterna to prove by Glock kundo
and/or stools of this result and
actually doing a bit more using but it's
the similar basic philosophies also
using some absorbing type method but but
a very different once or more
combinatorial one so they somehow do
this absorbing in steps so they drove
over to it iteratively okay so we now
have at least two proofs of this of this
result and okay so meaning we understand
when we can in these hypergraphs in
these complete hypergraphs cover them
with complete clicks now one thing we
don't really understand yet in the non
graph case is when we can do it with
resolvable with resolvable steiner
systems so that that is still open and
so far it's not clear how these methods
can be used for this but what I want to
spend the rest of the talk about is
rather to go away from this setting
there we just have complete graphs or
complete hypergraphs to more general
graphs yes that would be what I mainly
want to talk about and so and for the
rest of the talk I mainly want to focus
on on graphs because in this more
general setting already there there are
many things that we don't really
understand very well yet but you could
have the same definitions for hypergraph
sent this also has been looted a little
bit okay so let me know state but the
more general setting is that I want to
look at so we have some graph G now that
before used to be our complete hyper
graph on n vertices but now
oh you can take some other graph if you
want to and and let's just write G for
guest graph and then I have a family of
host graphs so h1 up to HK and I want to
pack these into this into this gas graph
and what does it mean it means that we
get edge disjoint copies of these hoes
graphs in the garage now here's a
picture for example if I have these
three horse perhaps that I want to pack
into this G another way of seeing this
definition is what I have to do is just
color the edges of this horse graph such
that each of the colors gives you one of
these so they should be the copies
should be edge just joined sorry it
should be edge disjoint but of course
they can be used vertices and they don't
have to use all the edges of the guests
rough but there could be some some edges
which are left over ok so that's the
setting and I mean for complete graphs
or hypergraphs it's really just the same
thing as we as we looked at before and
and he is one conjecture in this area
which has been around for quite some
time and it's kind of neat i find and
that's the so-called repacking
conjecture by ikea posh and now what
does it say it says so you want to pack
now in the complete graph on n vertices
and what you want to pack is a family of
tree and of trees and I really allow you
to present any family of trees that you
want to me the only condition that I
have is that tree number i should have
exactly i vertices so maybe i could have
left t1 out of here and t2 is also not
so interesting but ok so that's the
general set up so you can really come up
with any family of trees with this
property that you want and then the
conjecture says then I should be able to
pack them into
graph on n vertices so here's some
example on on six vertices and as you
see here already if I do this packing I
use all the edges of my complete graph
and that's of course not only true in
this particular example but it's true in
general and that's um how much one could
see as a little bit as the magic of this
conjecture is that if you come together
the number of the edges in these trees
that's exactly n chose to so in other
words what you want is a perfect packing
so perfect packing being really always
mean that we may need to use all the
edges oh ok so that's one conjecture and
but there are other similar conjectures
in the area and let me just mention one
other one which has been actually around
a little bit longer already now ringer
and 63 already conjectured that if you
just give me one tree and now on n plus
1 vertices then I can pack 2 n plus 1
copies of this tree into the complete
gravel to n plus 1 vertices yeah and if
you know if you calculate again if this
would be true again you would need a
perfect packing in order to do that and
and there are some variations on these
on these conjectures for example in
bipartite graphs and complete bipartite
graphs and something ok so they are and
some conjectures about packing trees
into complete webs around and for a long
time we we really didn't know very much
on these conjectures and I will
summarize it on a slide the future a
little bit but this is why somebody
cuadros actin came up with it with the
following idea and said well maybe if
somehow these conjectures are hard in
particular now if you look at this one
then maybe we could introduce something
to make our life easier arms and and his
idea basically was that so what to how
about if you use some symmetry would
that baby help as in looking at these
questions and there he invented
the notion of a graceful labeling and
there's also a famous conjecture
attributed to Rosa in connection with
this and I just want to show you that
this also has something to do with these
with these packing problems now what's a
graceful labeling now graceful labeling
is a labeling of the vertices of a graph
it's number one up to but in this case
of a tree then I have numbers from 1 up
to n and it is graceful if now whenever
I look at the labor links at this
labeling induces on the edges so I look
at some edge and what's de labeling and
used on the edge whether it's simply the
difference of the two labels and
absolute value now whenever I look at
these labels on the edges and then there
should all be distinct so that's a
graceful labeling what does it have to
do with these packing with the specking
problem that I mentioned before well if
I can gracefully label a tree then I can
also pack k copies of this tree or
grapple generally into the complete
graph kk on at least two times the
number of vertices of my graph minus one
many vertices now how do I do this well
I just start putting one copy now these
are the vertices of my complete graph I
didn't put the edges now imagine that
they are that they are labeled from one
to three and so on so the first copy i
just put it precisely in the way that
this labeling suggests to me okay so
that's certainly fine well then the
second copy I do exactly the same but I
rotated by ones and then the third copy
i rotate again and so on and so on and
this property of being having it right
for labeling and that the number of
vertices is not too small guarantees to
me that I won't use any any edge twice
yeah so we get a packing of copies of
this tree but we somehow get a very nice
packing a very symmetrical
okay and then the conjecture is of
course that every tree is graceful so
for every tree we can find actually good
so now what what what was known for this
conjecture until relatively recently so
people so people basically looked at a
very special families for now if you go
back to the trip packing conjecture
about the families of trees so already
in the original paper the efficient deal
they kind of considered paths and stars
or they consider the case where all the
trees in this family but to our stars so
there are very easy cases and then there
were some extensions of these results it
drops them for example in some series of
papers looked at what if I try to weaken
these conditions a little bit so if I
have trees with small diameters and also
have some vertex which made but
basically makes them look like a style
today were very isolated results what
maybe was a more general observation was
the observation type all of us so he
said okay now let's not be quite so
ambitious but let's just try to pick
some of these trees and then he showed
that well at least you can pack the
first and over square root too many
trees in this family by using some
density arguments now if you try and NT
pecks the end of a sparrow to smallest
of these trees now if you instead try to
pack as many of the big trees as you
want that took a lot longer and was only
done recently by pi log and Palmer who
showed that they can pack the roughly 1
over 10 to the N n to the 1 over 4
largest trees into the complete
good so that's what was done here now
for this graceful labeling conjecture
mean the idea was okay maybe some
symmetry helps us to obtain these
packings button kaji turned out that it
did that was even more hopeless yeah so
it was really only shown for some very
special trees which people gave funny
names to endure yeah that's all it was
known until recently and I apologize but
I didn't even put everything okay and
then a few years ago and return to this
problem and we thought okay maybe one
should kind of replicate what happened
in this story about about this china
systems maybe now we should try to use
some random some randomness and some
pseudo randomness in order to get near
perfect packings of trees so meaning we
don't want to get a pecking of our
families of treason in the complete
graph on n vertices but we allow
ourselves a little bit more space an
epsilon fraction of vertices more and
the theorem that we could prove is the
following now as I said we don't pack
into the computer on n vertices but we
pack on the complete graph on 1 plus
epsilon times n many vertices and okay
then we could weaken the conditions that
you have in the in the conjecture a
little bit just because we have this
more space so now we don't need to know
so precisely anymore how many vertices
it's tree has as long as we know that
there that it has at most n vertices and
then of course okay so not every tree of
course should be that big because that
would give me too many edges so I also
need a condition on how many edges I
have in total so I have at most as many
edges in total as I would have in the
complete graph on n vertices and then
but then we needed another restriction
it's made
the most serious restriction this
theorem we needed that the maximum
degree of our trees which I denote by
the state of Ti is that most some
constant data yeah but then no then now
if you have these conditions then we
were able to pack these trees into the
complete graph on 1 plus epsilon times
and many and ok that the probe in the
proof technique they also give some
similar and result for this ringer
conjecture which which which I repeat it
here but let me not go into this so now
let me very briefly just say a few
things about the proof so we be somehow
so again the basic philosophy of
establishing this theorem was let's try
to use a similar method as for the
Steiner system service am I wanted to
use some random process and they can be
thought okay let's let user it's let's
use a ruler nibble in order to to
achieve this result and an on hindsight
we know from today's perspective II
didn't very well know back then what to
do these things so and they mean why we
know a few things how to do the whole
story better but at the time what would
it be trying to do well so what did we
say for the world in a baby sent okay we
want to so back then we were embedding
these clicks and we said we want to
embed a few of these clicks randomly and
then stop and pause and think so now
here the situation is a bit different
because these trees that can be very big
so and already know if I try to embed
two of these trees there might be and it
would randomly then there's some serious
overlap and then it's not so clear what
I should do so then we said okay then we
somehow apparently need to chop up our
trees and two smaller bits and that's
precisely what we did we read somehow
chop them up into linear nice highest
sub trees and then we kind of try to run
this nibble approach on this sub tree so
embed a few of these sub trees
and then stop and take the edges that
you used out yeah now of course the
problem is you need to keep in mind that
at the end somehow you need to patent to
combine these sub trees together again
because they should in the end form of
one whole tree the problem is also and
so now when I said earlier about have
you bet these creeks I said okay some of
the clicks overlap so we just forget
about these clicks now this I cannot
quite do here right because so now if my
my trees overlap a little bit my sub
trees overlap a little but I don't want
to forget about them again because I
need them in the end yeah so we somehow
need to do something else then than just
throwing these sub trees out but we need
some money to repair these these random
positions of the subject okay that was
all very vague and I'm anyone to mention
it in order to show you what one can
actually do better and what wouldn't you
do differently but now one more thing is
also for randomly embedding these little
trees that I've obtained we somehow use
the very complicated random process and
that's what it kind of tried to
summarize on this slide and you don't
really have to read so much the main
message is really we somehow you some
complicated random process of what was
the process of course this was somehow
so here we have our little and sub tree
now we partitioned the vertices into its
true color classes and then we first
embed one color class which is easy so
we just randomly put it somewhere which
is nice because this one color class
will form an independent set and then we
just need to put in the other color
cards and we do that randomly as well
but now we have the restriction that if
we want to put this vertex random maybe
somehow have to embed it into the
neighborhood of these and better
courtesy sorry okay so that was the
process and it was somehow complicated
and it didn't it introduced a lot of
pain why was it so complicated well what
we were varied about at the time the
dependencies you know so and was really
that now if i randomly in bed
this tree then and I would just do it
one vertex by one vertex then very
dependent various practices and I saw
where that is but it's and that somewhat
depends on this vertex and what time are
clear from us that these at some point
is dependency should become negligible
but we really didn't know how to how to
analyze that at the time yeah so that's
why we somehow did it in a complicated
way okay so now in the meantime after
this result there were really a lot of
improvements on this and the first
reside in this direction was obtained by
mutual tree avoided and shaft who
actually first observed that so we did
this as I try to explain we cut our
trees into some linear sized but small
sub trees and they said well actually
one shouldn't do it this way one should
actually cut the tree into much smaller
bits one should cut it cut the tree into
constantly size bit and then kind of run
the same run something like the same
idea of doing things randomly and so on
but even for doing things randomly they
said well and why should we actually
know that we have constant size bits
there's no reason to reinvent the wheel
again but maybe we could rather use
these results from Russia to re-envision
about putting small creeks edge just
jointly into a complete graph so so we
could just reuse this reader and that's
that's there they are there proof idea
to reduce so to cut the trees into very
small bits and then we'd use the problem
with a lot of with some extra work and
to the problem of Russia Tory Anderson
to the theorem a brighter to envision
and they observed that if we do it like
this and actually we can embed we can
get a similar result not just for trees
but actually for a much much bigger
class of craft so what's and the much
bigger cars of grass it's the clouds of
graphs
yeah so for any non-trivial minor closed
family when you take some graphs there
and they again have found a degree then
you can obtain the analog of suicide to
the result that I showed you on the last
night so now what does it mean so why do
i right behind a closed family here well
that's basically because these graph
families allow separators so they allow
you to have some good separators and
that's what they want in order to cut up
these these graphs into small bits okay
good so that was one result then family
and Moosa they observed it okay now what
do we do if actually we don't just want
almost spanning graphs so what did I
mean by almost spending let me go back
to this recite because it because it
stated and for here so here we said all
the autographs that I'm embedding I
allowed to have most n vertices and he
and bear in the host graph in the
complete graph I have epsilon n vertices
more so they are only almost spending
and they cannot cover really all the
vertices and that's what that's what
they changed so they again prove the
result where you don't use all use up
all the edges in your packing so you
only have a near-perfect packing but now
you are allowed to use all the vertices
in in your perhaps that you are
embedding and then very recently if ever
in some OT they are not pained some
results now again about trees so not
about this material grad classes where
they weaken this maximum degree
condition so all this year is for graphs
with max with constant maximum degree
and now and they can do some so much
larger maximum degree no n over log and
if you're almost spending end of about n
to the 16 if you are if you want
spending
okay and now going a peg from this
bigger maximum do we think killed Coonan
or Suzanne champion showed now again for
bounded degree graphs that actually even
this restriction about having separators
you don't need but one can actually do
it for any class of bound it across let
me stay for one second with with this is
it so what this shows is that if you're
in this setting off of almost perfect
packings then okay when can translate
the the tree packing conjecture to this
setting and then get this result but
actually in this setting of obtaining
almost perfect packings we can get much
much stronger packing beside so you can
really have much more general classes of
grass which we can pack in this scenario
okay we're now returning to the to the
tree packing conjecture there recently
also there was some some breakthrough
which builds on this work actually and I
will explain in a second by use
component oestrus and then our show that
indeed the tree pecking conjecture is
true as long as n is sufficiently large
and my trees have founded maximum ok so
now okay and so this I will talk a
little bit more about in a second just
briefly to mention to come back to these
squares for labor links that i mentioned
earlier which are which are kind of
stronger than these these pecking
questions also here in the setting where
we want not graceful labelings but near
graceful everything's now what do I mean
I mean I told you I want to label my
vertices from 1 up to n such that all
the edge labels are different and so now
here you don't allow yourself only
labels from 1 up to n but you allow
yourself labels from one up to 1 plus
epsilon n so a few labels more and in
this setting at a magical in Russian
lucky they could also prove such a
result and even for
for high maximum degree of the trees so
maximum degree and overlook ok so now
let's get back to this breakthrough
desired by us communion Oscars and how
do they prove this result now they start
off by showing something which is called
a blow of lemma in the in the packing
setting and they they combine that with
again some some absorbing technique so I
won't say anything about the absorbing
technique but let me tell you just very
briefly what what a blow-up lemma is now
here we come true again to some
different notion of very deep pseudo
randomness which is called regularity
and I want I mean I didn't even I was a
bit lazy I didn't even write on the
formal definition of regularity but in
the next target my eyes talk Shiva I
think two things a little bit more
carefully than I do here so now what's
in what's an epsilon regular pair to say
bipartite graph where I have that
whenever I choose a linear least highest
subset in one of the partition classes
and one in the other partition glass
then the density of the edges that I see
here is very close to the density of
edges that I see in the hologram yeah so
somehow the edges are quite uniformly
distributed and that is what is an
absolute mckillop here now why are these
why are these objects nice and important
then is an important because some radius
regularity lemma tells us that we can
partition every graph into objects of
this kind let's maybe all that I want to
say about them now what is a blow-up
lemma but the blow-up lemma says that if
we have such an epsilon regular pair and
okay we need one more addition the
condition that's why it's now called
super regular and that just says that
each vertex here should see should
should have enought to small degree
okay so now if I have such an F in rigor
yeah with some position on the degrees
then the blower glamour by Congress a
consumer ed tells me that actually
that's very nice for embedding copies of
graphs now with this setting just one
copy of graph and indeed they can embed
any bipartite graph H which is
compatible with this regular pay in the
sense that the number of vertices that I
want to embed here is precisely the
number of vertices that i have here and
they are the same so it is a spanning
graph and this drug should have maximum
degree at most debt yeah but under these
restrictions I can really embed this
spanning sub graph inside any such
epsilon D super regular ok and now what
did what was shown for this solution of
maximum degree tree attacking conjecture
was in a lot and all of this result for
not putting just one copy but putting
many copies and namely put in so many
that i get actually a near-perfect
packing good so that's how they obtained
this and we recently now return to the
question and kind of wanted to ask again
yes fine but how do we obtain packing
zhonya per perfect packings for four
graphs with bigger maximum degree so
again here the main restriction was that
the maximum degree is bounded by some
constant and I now of course the
question is how do we get rid of this
constant and we also kind of returned to
our methods that we that we had used
earlier already and kind of wanted to
say okay we had this complicated random
process would be really nice to to
replace it by a much simpler random
process and now that's what I would end
a simpler random process that's what i
want to show you on this page so some
somehow some very nature random process
but as i said because of dependencies we
didn't know how to analyze such things
at the time but now we are maybe a
little bit wise or something so but what
would actually be is or not if i give if
you give me some guests grass you want
up to GT and i want to pack them into
age what would be the most nature way to
do it somehow the most natural way to do
it is and I somehow want to do it
randomly is ok I first mpeg-1 then I am
a g2 and then I embed g3 and so on and
while I do this random embedding
whenever I embed an edge I would he take
out this edge because I don't want to
use it again ok so now when I embed my
eyes graph in this sequence then it is
through some order in which I want to
embed the vertices and that usually
should satisfy some conditions but ok
you are free to choose the order that
you want which is nice for you and then
I just embed vertex by vertex remembered
my word first vertex somewhere randomly
now the second vertex it mean if it has
an edge to this first vertex I cannot
invert it anywhere but I have to embed
it in the neighborhood of this vertex ok
but so I just look at the neighbor
of this vertex here and I am ready
trending Lee into this neighborhood and
then I just continue in this way so
third vertex embed renting me into this
neighborhood this vertex maybe doesn't
have any any a neighbor stare so again
again again embedded randomly but of
course I shouldn't embed it on anything
that I used before already so it should
embedded randomly on whatever remains
next one the same and now again maybe I
have some vertex which already has three
embedded neighbors so what do I need to
do is I need to look at the common
neighborhood in the horse trough of
these three vertices we sat and there
again I embedded render me and that's
what I do and and I just continue at
some point i'm done with this copy of
authors GI and then i continue with the
next graph and so on so i do it randomly
i never reuse any edges i take care that
my embeddings are really proper
embedding so when I embed the red graph
I don't reuse any vertices but under
these restrictions I do it randomly and
what what what would the Hopi the hope
would be after I did it for some copies
of GI then somehow now of course I
cannot reuse these edges anymore that I
used already so you could think about
them as being deleted and the hope would
now be that what I left it is somehow
quasi random in some sense similarly as
in this will prove so that then I can
still repeat my random process so
somehow we would need to show that such
a random process preserves some suitable
quasi randomness property ok so and now
very recently using exactly an approach
like this we managed to prove the
following near-perfect packing theorem
together with and in latakia and PG
where we look at a very general graph
class of grass so called degenerate
grabs now what's when is a graph
degenerate the prophecy generator if I
can order the vertices
from from one up from x 1 up to x and
such that now whenever I look at the eye
its vertex in this may in this order and
only look at the neighbors that it has
two vertices which came before in the
order so I only look at vertices it's
one absolute leagues i minus 1 and there
it has at most D neighbors and you
should think of D as a constant yeah but
on the other side and the ordering it
can have as many neighbors as it once so
that's a degenerate graph and now we peg
families of these TD generate graphs
with rather high maximum degree so we
allow maximum degree up to some small
constant times n divided by log so
that's what we want to pack these graphs
are now allowed to be spending so we
pack in the complete graph and they are
allowed to have n vertices but again
it's an onion almost perfect packing so
the the number of edges that we are
allowed to have been torturous needs to
be an epsilon fraction less than the
total number of edges that I have in KN
now but under these conditions and again
under the condition that my n is large
we can pack these grubs and and so this
now covers really more general class of
graphs than all the previous near
perfect packing reasons and what we use
in order to prove this is exactly this
this random process that I showed you on
the last slide so we use this natural
and and packing process to pick almost
spending graphs and then we need to show
that throughout this process we somehow
preserve quasi randomness now what's the
quasi randomness property that be was an
hour approve it it's like it's as
follows so whenever we take a set of
vertices in a graph of a certain size l
there is some constant and now we look
at the common neighbors of these as
vertices in the graph then that should
be very close to what one expects yes so
and p is the density of the graph so
that's how many so i have been taught to
p times n choose too many edges and so
that's the number of common neighbors
that i would expect p to the s times n
and I'm very close to this number so
that's the quasi randomness notion that
we use now why is this nature know if
you think back of our process I said for
example at this point I want to embed
this vertex in the common neighborhood
of these three vertices and then it
would be really nice if I have some
information about the common
neighborhood of these three vertices
throughout my process and that's what
this quazy randomness notion provides me
with ok and now but that's not that's
not quite enough we need a little bit
more so what we also show is that now
when we embed one of our grabs then
these common neighborhood saw so this
tells me something about the common
neighborhoods in my hosts graphs
throughout the MA packing problem but
now I have this other problem that when
I embed one graph we did my guest Robin
maybe it has nice pseudo randomness
properties in the sense that I know that
the common neighborhood of these three
vertices is nice and big and now when I
come and I embed my current graph here
at the moment and it could be that I
embedded already some vertex he embedded
some vertex here but it some vertex here
and later I want to embed some common
neighborhood neighbor of these three
vertices yeah but maybe in the meantime
before i come to the embedding of this
common neighbor a lot of more embeddings
happen and it could happen to me that i
eat up this common neighborhood by these
other random embeddings and that would
be bad because then i would come and i
would never place anymore to put the
common neighbor so that's something we
need to show in addition that this
doesn't happen that these common
neighborhoods are eaten up kind of
fairly so they're all eaten up in
same in the same ratio as well then I'm
not at the very end of the process then
I will still have some vertices left in
each of these family the proof you use
this L only up to D or do you need
further we need a little bit more than T
but maybe to D plus something like this
but for some technical reasons but I
mean it is actually a good point so you
don't want to use whatever this L is in
order to to show this property because
then somehow your L would blow up so you
need to stop somewhere it's not
precisely d but it's something like 2d
okay and then one thing we need to do
when we do this embedding so as I told
you of the earlier to you earlier vivir
a frightened of these dependencies so be
someone only to control these
dependencies but we now have tools in
order to control it what i call
sequential dependencies or what do i
mean well i mean that but one of the
trees then of course where some later
vertices end up my SD depends on bear
put some earlier vertices okay and we do
this random in this random process not
as i like you a little bit so we don't
do this this random process for the
holographs that we want to embed because
remember we want to get spinning and
spinning graphs that that we want a bed
but we only do it for some almost
spanning fraction of the graphs and then
at the end of course we have to extend
that to get really am spending copies
but how do we do that well we take away
some purchases at the beginning and then
at the end we your some matching
argument in order to extend through the
spinning graphs okay but that's maybe
rather technical so let me not say that
so I have one more slide which is about
these sequential dependencies but let me
maybe not even spare out this
horrible Emma because it's already three
o'clock in the afternoon and maybe it
gets a little bit much let me just say
that we can develop we developed tools
and actually in some earlier papers like
for example is Nia graceful labeling
papers some similar methods have been
developed in order to handle these
dependencies now and so we have some
llamas which precisely apply to this
situation that we have that we have some
random process which somehow proceeds
randomly but whatever happened in the
past mildly influences what happens what
happens in the future and the trick
religious is to go back to some non
martingale inequalities and in this case
we go back to Friedman's martingale
inequality and I mean that that's what
one should do that was clear to us a few
years ago but we just didn't know the
right tools at the time now it turns out
it is not actually certificate and it
was probably more our fear of the of the
dependencies that and then anything else
that kept us from doing okay but let me
not mention the details of this let me
rather come to concluding remarks so for
obtaining our new resolve Eustace what I
call natural random packing process and
the nice thing about this process that's
a very simple process so I think it
should actually be powerful and one hope
would be but this is not clear at all at
the moment is that this can maybe at
some point some more be combined with
some for example some iterative
absorption method was a mother
absorption method in order to actually
get some perfect packing yeah so this is
so when they reside about the perfect
packing result concerning the trip back
in conjecture that I showed you the main
restriction was that we can't can only
handle trees with constant maximum
degree at now the question is really how
does one get away from that our packing
process can do relatively large degrees
I mean there still is this barrier at
log n but okay at least we can do that
large degrees and maybe one could at
some point combine it with some some
similar absorption techniques in order
to get perfect packing results in that
setting that would be very nice why
would it be very nice well I mean having
this perfect packing result for trees of
constant maximum degree is already great
considering that we didn't know much
until a few years ago but most trees
actually don't have constant maximum
degree so a random tree for example has
maximum degree of the order log n so
doing something with maximum degrees of
order n over log and would already be
great because at least it would cover
most trees that are out there okay then
of course the question would be how
about very high decrease I mean both in
the near perfect packing as well as in
the perfect packing then how could I
hand vertex degrees which are even
higher and then the next question would
be heard about hypergraph versions of
forties of all these packing results
where much is known so far yet and that
would have some getting some serious
with out there that would be really nice
and it could have some applications of
towards getting these resolve ability
signs kind of thinking in there very
long long run okay so that's that and
that's just a very tight packing of
fries or more general objects and their
many things
[Applause]
any questions so you mentioned and by
natural random packing but you briefly
mention also this yeah graceful
conjecture this is also it's also a
random process so I mean it's a
different random process is because you
have to do something different and you
have to be yeah it I mean well it was on
the same slide yes so no I mean it's a
similar type of random process but it's
it's certainly different than this
process that that we use no hear it at
the end so they also somehow partition
dead trees and through the to partition
classes and then you do different things
for the petition class class but it's
rather nature in that settings because
to somehow control yes so that I mean so
since they can go with their process
because they also kind of then use these
modern techniques to control
dependencies they can go up to maximum
degree n over log n so therefore they
get random traces nicorette as our new
graceful yeah no I mean I think graceful
nothing is no I'm really grateful no
they are really just these banana tree
results
any other questions that's much a
question right so right let's thank the
speaker
[Applause]